ouais
donc là comme vous pouvez le voir de
lecture et des foires gigantesque
c'est une opération de dessécher
d'oreille dans le but de développer du
logement de l'emploi de la croissance à
l'échelle nationale
notre nice qui est un lycée en fête
agricole et donc mon groupe d'élèves là
ici présents sont des seconds général
mais ils ont un module d'exploration qui
est spécifique au ministère
l'agriculture à l'enseignement agricole
et qui s'appelle écologie agriculture
territoire développement durable est
donc dans le cadre de ce module
j'ai cherché donc à travailler sur un
territoire en particulier proche de
lycée et a montré un petit peu la
problématique d'aménagement les conflits
d'usagé éventuellement qu'il peut y
avoir sur ce territoire
les spécificités et donc le plateau de
sacrée été un très bon territoire
justement pour enquêter dessus tous les
élèves c'est intéressant parce que c'est
s'intéresser à différents domaines donc
et à différents acteurs surtout donc
finalement c'est en pluridisciplinarité
avec plusieurs disciplines
l'histoire-géo de l'agronomie
l'économie l'écologie aussi
l'aménagement qui est prévu donc avec la
densification d'entreprise de structures
de recherche de structures
d'enseignement
pour nous de toute façon c'est un atout
pour pour l'établissement parce que
c'est une façon aussi de de faire venir
des élèves qui pourront faire une
poursuite d'études ensuite sur ce
territoire sachant que nous nous avons
un internat nous avons des élèves car il
aussi de loin donc c'est vrai que c'est
pas la c1 une attractivité
en plus on va dire pour notre
établissement le projet paraît sa cure
il est bénéfique sur tous les plans
autre il pense qu'il y aura de nouvelles
entreprises des dépassements y aura des
logements y aura des espaces verts à la
base
mes débuts je voulais les faire à la
sorbonne
donc maintenant avec tout ce que j'ai
appris aujourd'hui
j'envisage aussi de contenus continuer
d'étudier